sweet this is steven Kristoff's director
of external affairs of rich total
combination pack the question is how can
I Asia lead the world leading the world
comes from economic power and economic
power comes from interact with other
economies and being quite open about it
so how can i delete the world it has to
become very competitive and it's not
just about competition I details I
manufacturing its competition of thought
it's a competition of leadership it's
competition at what actually drives so
it's going to lead the world by becoming
less incidence lead the world by
becoming far more of the global
community I'll also say that dancing
will lead on block it will be the
country's leading a certain targets but
what we will see is a massive change in
how the rest of the world relates to the
Asian